Google pixel 8 Pro Google pixel 8 sont
des smartphones dont je vous ai pas
encore parlé qui pourtant sont vraiment
bien et que j'utilise déjà depuis un bon
petit moment notamment mon pixel 8 que
j'ai emmené un peu partout j'ai fait
Glob trotter avec donc je vais vous
donner mon retour et vous dire pourquoi
en quoi ces smartphones sont assez
différents des autres smartphone qu'on
peut retrouver sur Android il y a un
parti prix de Google une direction très
intéressante à commencer par lia je vous
parle pas trop tout de suite du Google
pixel 8 qui reste malgré tout une très
très bonne copie mais on va regarder le
modèle qui va le plus loin c'est-à-dire
le pixel pro on prend donc le pixel 8 on
le met sur le côté on l'isole le pixel 8
Pro quant à lui est un smartphone très
intéressant c'est fatalement le plus
cher des smartphone sur Google
aujourd'hui bien évidemment s'il vous
intéresse je vous mets un lien d'illeurs
même pour le pixel 8 lien juste en bas
dans la description en quoi ce
smartphone est intéressant bien tout
simplement parce que Google prend un
parti qui est assez à part on l'a vu
arriver déjà il y a 2 ans en mettant sa
puce Google tensort la G1 à l'intérieur
on est sur la G3 ce que Google se dit
avec cette puce et on va venir proposer
des usages fait pour Google fait par
Google pour de Lia et on voit que lia
c'est un sujet qui se développe
énormément avec notamment lia génératif
et bien Google est venu mettre vraiment
beaucoup d'IA et encore plus d'IA grâce
à Gini mais ça je vous en parle dans
quelques instants vous allez voir c'est
superpr intéressant et je vous en ai
parlé il y a pas longtemps je vous
emmener avec moi à Hawaii vous présenter
le Snapdragon 8 Gen 3 le nouveau
processeur de Qualcom qui commence à
arriver sur des smartphones dans cette
fin d'année qu'on retrouvera énormément
en 2024 et bien il y a de Lia à
l'intérieur avec le modèle de M laama 2
ici c'est pas la même chose c'est Gini
Gini c'est le modèle de Google c'est un
peu le JPT 4 de Google qui permet
d'avoir plein de fonctionnalités hyper
cool et dès maintenant aujourd'hui dans
son pixel 8 Pro et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant avant de vous montrer ça je
veux qu'on fasse un petit tour complet
de ce smartphone pour essayer de voir ce
qui est intéressant ce qui fonctionne ce
qui fonctionne pas déjà Google c'est
l'expérience Android j'ai passé très
rapidement là-dessus parce que vous
connaissez tous Android bien évidemment
sur le pixel c'est encore plus fort que
sur tous les smartphones Android avec
vos petites vos petits petit rappel que
vous AZ trouvé là dans votre agenda 100
% Android bien évidemment vos
différentes applications bref c'est
intéressant ça marche bien c'est cool
par contre moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
ce très grand écran 6,7 pouces
extrêmement lumineux OL LED ltpo on va
de 1 Hz jusqu'à 120 Hz donc un
smartphone qui va être très bon pour
toutes les expériences de gaming avec
beaucoup de fluidité si vous regardez
des films des séries il va descendre un
peu plus bas si vous liseer on va aller
encore plus bas sur du always on display
on sera à 1 Hz surtout en terme
d'autonomie ça vient à améliorer
l'expérience c'est pas son gros point
fort ça va ça fonctionne on aurait pu
souhaiter une bien meilleure autonomie
mais bon vous êtes déjà une très bonne
journée donc bon ok bon il y a un autre
truc qui m'intéresse sur ce smartphone
c'est que je le trouve vraiment bien
fini alors on aurait toujours tendance à
se dire ok mais alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe là parce que mon bloc photo il est
proéminent il ressort et en le mettant
sur une table comme ça est-ce qu'on rque
pas un peu de l'endommager en l'ayant
utilisé depuis un petit moment j'ai pas
de souci particulierers de rayures voyez
j'ai beau regarder des rayures des micro
rayures j'en ai pas ici Google vous a
mis le dernier verre de Corning le
Gorilla glace victus 2 qui est très bon
vous avez un cadre en aluminium il est
beau il est bien fini personnellement
j'aime bien alors il est assez grand
attendons c'est c'est un très très gros
smartphone forcément pour accueillir une
dalle de 6,7 pouces il faut un grand
smartphone donc bon si vous cherchez un
smartphone un peu plus petit allez sur
le pixel 8 vous voyez il est quand même
moins large moins haut plus petit écran
on ira moins loin en photo ça sera la
même puce il y a quelques différences
mais ça reste aussi une très très bonne
copie maintenant le truc qui est
vraiment fort ici qui est super
intéressant c'est toute la partie photo
vous avez un capteur principal de 50
mégapixel on peut venir filmer grâce à
ce capteur en 4K à 60 image par seconde
la vidéo est très cool et je vous montre
dans quelques instants donc déjà de base
tout ce qui va rentrer dans l'appareil
va être capté de très bonne qualité on
peut regrouper plusieurs pixels pour
sortir un seul et même gros pixel et ça
c'est vachement bien en condition de
faible luminosité avec de Lia derrière
c'est fou furieux je vais vous montrer
vous avez un téléobjectif de 48
mégapixel avec un zoom optique x 5 et
puis un ultra grand temps 48 mégapixel
qui fait également de la macro donc on
voit qu'on a beaucoup de polyvalance ici
au niveau du bloc photo ce qui est
vraiment intéressant à venir se rendre
compte ici c'est que tout le process
d'image en passant à travers l'optique
le capteur et ensuite tout l'algo qu'on
va retrouver à l'intérieur et
l'intelligence artificielle que Google
va venir mouliner bien vous donne un
résultat absolument incroyable là le
ciel est maîtrisé les nuages sont très
jolis toute cette lave séchée est
magnifique je vous emmène à hawaaii on
est à Maoui je vous montre sur
différentes configurations alors bon là
les surfer au loin peut venir zoomer
alors plus on zoome moins c'est bon mais
pour autant voyez ça c'est intéressant
parce que ça fait vraiment un stop sur
l'image des fois c'est un peu trop
poussif et c'est vraiment ce que je vais
reprocher à ce smartphone là voyez au
niveau de la photo ça fonctionne selfie
on passe sur un grand grand plus selfie
qui fonctionne très bien aussi ok ça ça
marche voyez avec les paysages derrière
toujours les surfurs donc on avance
rapidement alors attention quand on
vient zoomer un petit peu trop voyez ça
lisse énormément et ça c'est pas fou on
part de très loin quand même faut se le
dire on part à peu près d'ici et on
vient énormément zoomer là c'est sympa
là c'est pareil les statues en mode
portrait c'est Halloween un peu de
partout il y a beaucoup de poules
sauvages sur de la nourriture regardez
c'est quand même vachement bien ça donne
très faim là ce steak comme ça sauf si
vous êtes végan je suis désolé les
patates c'est sympa des poussins c'est
bien a du détail au niveau des plumes ça
c'est vraiment un truc qui marche
vraiment bien regardez là c'est super
joli sur des fleurs aussi la macro c'est
cool regardez ça c'est super joli on a
tout le détail ici c'est super efficace
sur une tortue aussi on voit bien tout
ce qu'elle est en train de manger alors
là j'ai zoomé et on le voit parce que
forcément j'ai pas eu coller devant la
tronche on le voit un petit peu voyez
par ici on voit que c'est venu un peu
lisser c'est venu améliorer l'image on
un peu de bruit également mais au-delà
de ça c'est quand même super joli avec
le soleil en pleine face ça marche aussi
super bien une fois de plus c'est
vraiment vraiment efficace alors
normalement on le met pas sous l'eau
pour faire des photos on le recommande
pas il est certifi ép 68 on évite de
trop le mettre mais si vous voulez vous
marrer pouvez le faire un petit peu le
truc qui va être compliqué c'est si vous
êtes dans une zone d'ombre et que c'est
très exposé de l'autre côté comme il va
venir chercher avec l'algo à venir faire
ressortir un peu tout ce qu'il y a là
c'est un peu la limite et là c'est pas
pas terrible terrible l'expo derrière là
voyez elle est pas folle c'est pas joli
il a du mal à faire ça ça c'est vraiment
la limite du truc bien évidemment les
photos prises comme ça là il va avoir
vraiment du mal à venir vous faire
ressortir regardez autre limite ici
alors ça c'est mon fils je lu cache la
tête vous voyez vous avez beaucoup de
bruit ici il vient chercher à compenser
là expo est pas bonne regardez là
derrière là au niveau de la végétation
c'est magnifique je découv je vous
balade un peu en même temps regardez ça
aussi ça marche très très bien une fois
de plus efficace là regardez c'est super
joli petite balade dans les bambous
alors la nuit il marche extrêmement bien
c'est un des très gros points forts
qu'on a dans ce pixel 8 Pro on peut
venir faire des expos extrêmement
longues pour faire de
l'astrophotographie c'est pas vraiment
ce que j'ai cherché à faire ici j'avais
un peu trop de pollution lumineuse en
plus là c'est pareil je vous emmène à
3000 m vers l'observatoire en haut du
volcan il vous sort des photos qui sont
vraiment juste à couper le souffle vous
avez plusieurs volcans dans le cratère
en fait plusieurs cheminées je pass
c'est des volcons des cheminééses dans
le cratère c'est magnifique
l'Observatoire qui est là on peut bien
regarder de plus près sans dégrader la
qualité et là vous avez plein de petits
oiseaux voyez les panoramas c'est
vraiment lunaire c'est c'est vraiment
très très très joli caméra de selfie
assez efficace pas la meilleure mais
c'est efficace coucher de soleil aussi
voyez là il bosse vraiment vraiment bien
et alors là c'est pendant Halloween on
va avoir plein de petites déco de
bagnole et ce qui nous intéresse c'est
vraiment cette gestion au niveau des
lumières voyez la nuit tout est bien
exposé tout est juste la vidéo je vous
montre un petit peu ici petite surf
voyez le suivi là au niveau du surfer
c'est quand même extrêmement efficace je
suis à la main je zoome c'est fluide
c'est net ça c pas c'est extrêmement
bien stabilisé là c'est pareil voyez en
venant zoomer je cherche à le trouver
j'arrive à l'avoir alors forcément on a
une dégradation au niveau de la qualité
avec les petits poussins aussi là pe
venir zoomer dedans ça reste Cali ça
bouge pas c'est très très cool pareil
avec les petits Piaf là donc je trouve
qu'il y a vraiment un rendu de l'image
aussi lorsqu'on vient filmer en vidéo
qui est très très bon pour moi
aujourd'hui le meilleur vidéophone ça
reste l'iPhone mais là ce que nous
propose Google avec son pixel 8 Pro ils
ont vraiment pas à rougir c'est très
facile très stable très net pour venir
shooter ça c'est vraiment aussi un gros
gros point fort alors ça c'est les
photos qui sont prises directement mais
on peut aller beaucoup plus loin grâce
aux nouveautés logiciel qu'on retrouve
ici sur Android 14 et encore il y a
plein de nouvelles fonctionnalités qui
arrivrive avec ce qu'on app les drop
features je vous explique dans quelques
instants je vais vous montrer mais tenz
regardez je vous montre cette photo par
exemple à droite là j'ai des gens dans
mon qui se baladent et moi j'ai pas
envie d'avoir ces gens-l ça m'embête je
faudrait les éliminer je juste garder
mes poules j'adore mon cadrage de poule
le cadrage est pourri mais j'adore cette
photo et je veux uniquement garder mes
poules et je veux pas les gens à côté et
bien ce que je fais c'est que je vais
dans modifier alors il y a système de
gomme magique qui est pratique mais vous
voyez je vais cliquer juste en bas à
gauche ici là et là je vais pouvoir
venir sélectionner ce qui me dérange
donc là c'est vraiment eu deux qui me
dérange donc là je viens balayer dessus
directement ça me les a sélectionné et
ensuite j'ai qu'à cliquer sur Effacer en
bas et là ça va venir me générer du
contenu en venant supprimer ce que j'ai
sélectionné et en venant créer du
contenu pour le remplacer et là la scène
est quand même assez complexe regardez
ils étaient là on est d'accord ils
étaient là je réappuie sur ma photo ils
réapparaissent donc ça m'a supprimé met
la statue derrière voyez là j'avais une
porte comme ça là et ben là ça m'a
regénéré une espèce de portefenêtre ça
m'a généré ça derrière ça c'est la
proposition numéro une proposition
numéro 2 et bien voyez là ça m'a généré
encore une espèce d'arbuste derrière et
en numéro 3 là ça m'a généré quoi ça m'a
généré cette espèce de plante donc le
truc pour moi est vraiment bluffant
parce que on voit que c'est très
compliqué c'est très complexe ici et je
peux venir supprimer très très
facilement donc ça c'est le premier
point voyez par exemple là c'est
intéressant je suis là en train de me
prendre en photo je vais avir ir les
rochers sur les côtés et en fait ce que
je voudrais c'est avoir ma tête mais
légèrement sur le côté et bien regardez
de la même manière je vi cliquer sur
Modifier je clique en bas à gauche je
vais me sélectionner hop je me
barbouille un peu la tronche comme ça il
reconnaî que c'est moi donc là voyez il
fait le détourage extrêmement rapidement
je n'ai plus qu'à laisser appuyer sur
moi et je me décale par exemple sur la
gauche là en venant me zoomer légèrement
bon mon cadre est dégueulasse mais
imaginons que je vais faire ça là la
difficulté c'est qu'il va falloir qu'il
recrée du contenu ici dans toute cette
partie qui est assez complexe hop je
mets ici j'appuie en bas à droite et
c'est
parti et voilà regardez on peut aller
vachement loin si on regarde bien on
peut voir que le ciel n'est pas tout à
fait de la même teinte ici et ici entre
le moment où je me suis supprimé mais
globalement ta est quand même vachement
bien fait on voit la différence au
niveau des cailloux il y a toujours
cette ligne d'horizon qui est bien
respectée là ça remonte légèrement plus
au niveau de mon oreille là un petit peu
moins ça tire plus droit là ça redescend
un peu regardez les cailloux que ça m'a
généré là ce gros caillou derrière là il
est comme ça là c'est comme ça là c'est
comme ça enfin c'est juste extrêmement
bluffant il y a aucune limite
aujourd'hui on peut faire ce qu'on veut
et n'oublions pas qu'on part de là je
suis comme ça et ça me génère ça la
photo est un peu moins lumineuse on perd
quand même un petit peu en expo voyez
sur le côté mais ça j'imagine que Google
va venir le corriger pour nous apporter
des solutions qui vont être encore plus
pertinentes et je trouve ça extrêmement
fou et ça justement ça vient introduire
ce que Google appelle des futur drop des
futur drop c'est quoi et bien c'est
quelque chose qui va rendre votre
téléphone Google pixel encore plus
intelligent et pour le coup c'est que
les pixels qui font ça votre smartphone
va devenir plus en plus intelligent
c'est à peu près tous les 3 mois il vut
venir vous pousser de nouvelles
fonctionnalités ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que la Google a annoncé son modèle
d'intelligence artificiel qui s'appelle
Gemini Gemini il y a trois versions de
Gemini qui existent il y a l'ultra le
pro et le nano et le Nano c'est la plus
petite version et on peut la retrouver
directement dans les smartphones et
notamment aujourd'hui on vient
l'utiliser sur son pixel 8 Pro et ça
grâce à la puissance de la puce Google
tensor G3 plus JAMINI derrière on va
pouvoir avoir accès à de nouvelles
fonctionnalités basées sur de Lia
directement sur votre pixel 8 Pro ça
c'est qu'en anglais aujourd'hui mais ça
finira par arriver en français c'est du
résumé lorsque vous faites un audio vous
vous enregistrez ça va vous transcrire
ensuite en texte et lui ce qui va vir
faire ce qui va venir analyser votre
texte pour vous en faire un résumé sont
déjà des choses qu'on peut venir
retrouver sur le net mais c'est quand
même super efficace de l'avoir ici
directement dans son smartphone que vous
soyez en ligne ou h ligne des réponses
rapides et intelligentes directement
dans jboard vous recevez des messages ça
va venir vous proposer du contenu pour
répondre il y a plein de nouvelles
fonctionnalité qui arrive au niveau de
la photo et de la vidéo au niveau de la
stabilisation au niveau des time laaps
la nuit pour rendre les vidéos et les
photos encore plus nettes lorsque vous
prenez une photo et bien pour venir
supprimer la tâche de café et il y en a
énormément de nouveautés qui arrive ici
directement soit dans les pixel watch ce
soit dans les Google pixel pixel 8 Pro
donc ça c'est la grosse force de Google
avec son pixel 8 Pro c'estàd que vous
avez un smartphone qui va se réinventer
très régulièrement donc je dirais que
aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle si vous
êtes intéressé par l'A générative vous
avez un smartphone qui est très fort
très intelligent très malin c'est lui et
encore je vous ai montré assez peu de
choses il y a plein d'autres choses on
peut venir faire directement ici sur son
smartphone le pixel 8 Pro d'ailleurs
même le pixel 8 ce sont des smartphones
qui deviennent plus compétents plus
intelligents plus efficients
régulièrement au travers de ces mises à
jour et moi ce qui me bluff c'est que à
peine lancé PAF vous avez déjà JAMINI
ici dans votre pixel 8 Pro alors il faut
attendre qu'il pousse la future drop
aujourd'hui en France elle existe déjà
aux US mais ça ne serait tarder donc
vous voyez on a des smartphones qui sont
intelligents qui sont évolutifs superbe
écran performant qui fait aujourd'hui
des pixel 8 pixel 8 pixel 8 Pro des
smartphones un peu à part sur Android et
que pour le coup j'aime beaucoup et
d'ailleurs si vous avez pas encore vu
tout ce qui va arriver sur les
smartphones Android l'année prochaine
qui tourneront sur le Snapdragon 8 Gen 3
avec beaucoup d'intelligence
artificielle à l'intérieur allez voir
cette vidéo c'est extrêmement
intéressant